[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum philosophischen
stammtisch heute zum ersten mal aus dem
alten kraftwerk in basel
und auch heute leider wieder ohne
publikum dafür mit einem thema das uns
alle im kern betrifft was haben wir uns
doch alle geärgert als kinder wenn es am
tisch zu hause wieder einmal hieß wir
wollen doch nur dein bestes ja und wie
viel heikler wird der satz erst eine
nicht von den eltern ausgeht sondern vom
staat
und erst recht wenn er unseren körper
betrifft beispielsweise wenn es um eine
impfpflicht geht oder um nahrungsmittel
vorgaben im kampf gegen korona soll sie
es richten die impfung in allen ländern
der welt wird um impfstoff gebuhlt
allerdings wollen nicht alle die können
sich immunisieren lassen darf der staat
sie zwingen zum wohle aller
[Musik]
oder zumindest jene von veranstaltungen
ausschließen die sich nicht impfen
lassen wollen
also ohne impfung kein schul
fitnesscenter opern oder museumsbesuch
kein flug in den urlaub keinen besuch im
fußballstadion mit subtilen zwang das
volk erziehen
dies ist auch das ziel von zucker salz
und fett steuern die künstlich verteuern
was ungesund ist
oder gar wie etwa in mexiko seit kurzem
der fall ein verbot von fast food und
softdrinks oder höhere
krankenkassenprämien für raucher
verdecke und bewegungsmuffel
denn ungesund ernährt und fitness
abstinente werden schneller krank und
belasten das gesundheitssystem aber
gehört mein körper nicht mehr ist der
lebensstil nicht privatsache
der französische historiker und
philosoph michel foucault analysierte
dass die moderne staatsgewalt ist schon
seit langem vor allem auf die normierung
zähmung und optimierung unserer körper
abgesehen hatte sein begriff für diesen
zustand einer schleichenden
gesundheitsdiktatur biopolitik wem also
gehört mein körper mir ganz allein auch
den anderen oder gar den start
und wer darf im zweifelsfall entscheiden
was mit meinem körper zu geschehen hat
vier munter diskutierende leiber sollte
ja seien die einzig wirklich
verbindliche vorgabe an diesem
stammtisch zu dem ich sehr herzlich
begrüße svenja flaßpöhler
chefredakteurin des philosophie magazins
aus berlin und stefan riedener
philosophie ethik zentrum der
universität zürich schön sind sie da
vielen dank herr riedenheim mal
angenommen sie gehen mit ihrem besten
schulfreund um den see herum und dieser
eröffnet ihnen dass er sich auf gar
keinen fall gegen korona wird impfen
lassen er lasse sich da auch nicht
hereinreden das sei ganz allein seine
angelegenheit was erwidern sie da als
wohlgesonnener ethik experte
dem widerspreche ich vehement ob wir uns
impfen lassen oder nicht das geht aus
verschiedenen gründen auch andere
personen etwas an
der einfachste grund ist folgender wenn
wir das virus auf lesen stellt das ja
nicht nur ein übel früher und selber da
sondern wir stellen damit auch eine
unter umständen tödliche gefahr für
andere personen da wir haben eine
moralische pflicht andere personen nicht
zu gefährden sofern es uns nicht allzu
viel kostet diese gefährdung zu
vermeiden
er scheint unterdessen klar dass die
vorhandenen impfstoffe nicht nur die
wahrscheinlichkeit reduzieren dass wir
selber ankommt 19 erkrankten sondern
auch die wahrscheinlichkeit dass wir das
virus weiter geben außerdem haben alle
impfstoffe ein rigoroses
prüfungsverfahren durchgemacht und
scheinen im normalfall kein allzu großes
risiko für uns darzustellen insofern
glaube ich habe eine starke moralische
gründe
obwohl sogar eine moralische pflicht
anderen personen gegenüber uns zum
profispieler harry dena sieht sich klar
positioniert haben sie derartige
gespräche auch schon im bekanntenkreis
geführt ja ich lebe das natürlich in
wesentlichen zügen ähnlich dass wir es
hier mit mit einer technik zu tun haben
die eben tatsächlich auch fremdschaden
verhindert und nicht nur eigenen schaden
das ist tatsächlich das muss man
deutlich sagen ich würde aber trotzdem
darauf hinweisen dass wir auch keine
grippe eben pflicht haben bei der grippe
gibt es auch jedes jahr tote wir haben
auch einen regen autoverkehr der auch
jedes jahr tote erzeugte hervorbringt
das heißt wir leben
in einer gesellschaft die in vielerlei
hinsicht techniken zulässt oder oder
praktiken zulässt mit denen ich mich
nicht nur selbst gefährden sondern eben
auch andere gefährde
und da müssten wir dann finde ich
darüber reden bis zu einem welchen
gerade eine reine gesellschaft diese
risiken verantworten sollte oder sogar
muss damit sie eine liberale bleibt aber
da ist jetzt ja schon eine wichtige
unterscheidung glaube ich auf dem tisch
nämlich diejenige zwischen einer
moralischen pflichten einer rechtlichen
pflicht also wenn es ums autofahren geht
zum beispiel gibt's natürlich keine
rechts verbot aus zuzuschauen
aber es gibt philosophin und philosophen
die tatsächlich meinen wir sollten auch
aufhören auto zu fahren weil das zu
riskant ist für andere menschen zb und
wenn ich sie richtig verstanden habe
würden sie sagen es gibt eine klare
moralische pflicht aber es gibt
möglicherweise keine rechtliche pflicht
empirisch gesehen sind die schweizer
tatsächlich so dass das epidemien gesetz
nicht vorsieht dass man menschen zwingen
kann zu einer impfung wohl aber ist
vorgesehen dass es ein impfobligatorium
geben kann immer aber nur für bestimmte
exponierte gruppen also sonst gibt es
keinen impfzwang der schweiz rechtlich
gesehen
also ich würde sagen ganz prinzipiell
kann bei so einer krankheit veeco mit 19
ist auch legitim sein dass ein staat
eine impfpflicht verhängt also noch mal
wenn ich mich nicht impfen lasse stelle
ich auch eine gefahr für andere dar
der staat hat grundsätzlich das recht
andere personen von mir zu schützen also
grundsätzlich kann das auch legitim sein
dass der staat von mir verlangt nicht zu
impfen
dass das allerdings jetzt schon der fall
wäre mit den vorhandenen impfstoffen bei
coop 19 dass wir dich tatsächlich auch
bezweifeln ich glaube wir sollten
zunächst mal schauen wie viele personen
lassen sich freiwillig impfen und
erlangen die dadurch vielleicht schon
eine hinreichende herdenimmunität dann
sollten wir sicher sanfte formen des
zwangs sanfte maßnahmen in erwägung
ziehen wie zum beispiel das wir verfügen
dass bestimmte freiheiten der besuch von
großveranstaltungen das einladen von
großen gruppen im privaten nur für
geimpfte personen offen stehen und wenn
dann immer noch von ungeimpften personen
ein allzu große gefahr ausgeht dann
frühestens könnte mir eine staatliche
richtigen bewegung aber schaffen wir
doch mal kurz die intuition wenn diese
krankheit vier mal ansteckender und
macht mal tödlicher wäre dann hätten wir
die frage gar nicht dann wäre ich
vielleicht von staatlicher seite aus
nicht nur möglich sondern absolut
geboten also es gibt da
eine grenze wo hat man sagen müsste der
staat greift ein und wenn man diesen
imaginierten freund von ihnen zuhört
dann kann man ja zumindest sagen was du
da sagst das ist nur meine sache das
stimmt geben offenbar nicht allein
dadurch dass ich atme grenze ich die
freiheit die überlebens freiheit anderer
ein das heißt dieses grund liberaler
argument funktioniert noch gar nicht ich
bin ja selbst eher liberale seele aber
bei der impfpflicht würde ich sagen es
könnte sogar auch staatliche vorgaben
geben und es fällt mir schwer dagegen zu
argumentieren wenn man sich nur einen
virus vorstellen würde der leicht
vielleicht dieser mutierte virus
deshalb sage ich ja man muss genau
gucken bis zu welchem gerade kann eine
kann und muss eine gesellschaft sich
risiken leisten damit sie liberal bleibt
also wenn wir denn überhaupt diese idee
von autonomie von mündigkeit
liberalismus beibehalten wollen darüber
kann man natürlich diskutieren ob man
das wirklich will ja also ich möchte
dass zumindest dann müssen wir erstmal
den menschen als für sich verantwortlich
setzen für seinen eigenen leib
verantwortlich setzen und und dann kann
man natürlich darüber reden eben also
führt man meinetwegen tempolimits auf
autobahnen eine limitiert man risiken
schafft man oder oder ermöglicht man ich
sag mal sichere radwege und so weiter
darüber kann man ja diskutieren aber ich
glaube sich eine gesellschaft
vorzustellen
die jede form von risiko nicht nur für
meinen eigenen leib sondern auch für die
der anderen auszuschalten zu eliminieren
das ist notgedrungen eine totalitäre
gesellschaft
das ist natürlich jetzt ein harter
vorwurf der im raum steht wenn ich noch
einen schritt zurück gehen möchte ich
finde es schon wichtig noch einmal
festzuhalten worüber wir sprechen
nämlich dort jetzt gerade gesagt es
reicht eigentlich in der welt zu sein
und zu atmen und schon können wir
einander einschränken in einer pandemie
situation da wäre ich schon erstmal
vorsichtig es geht jetzt nicht um
verhaltensweisen es geht es nicht darum
dass sie einander verbieten gewisse
dinge zu tun die erwiesenermaßen
gefährlich oder schädigen sind wie
andere leute die möglicherweise menschen
erlauben waffen zu kaufen die keine
waschen scheine haben irgend so etwas
sondern alleine die existenz in dieser
welt zu sein und zu atmen reicht schon
aus um die gefährdung zu sein dass es
doch eine darstellung des des wesens des
menschen die mir schon
so finde ich jetzt bemerkenswerten so
formuliert ist das natürlich übertrieben
wenn ich als einsiedler in einer
einsamen hütte wohnen dann stelle ich
wohl für niemanden eine gefahr da aber
die meisten von uns bewegen sich in der
gesellschaft haben vielleicht berufe bei
denen sie täglich in kontakt mit
personen kommen also es ist schwer
völlig zu vermeiden durch das virus auch
eine gefahr für andere da zuständen und
ich möchte schon auch noch betont klar
es kann nicht die rede davon sein dass
wir keinerlei risiken mehr zulassen das
wollte ich auch überhaupt nicht sagen
aber dass corona virus ist nicht die
grippe ist es doch wesentlich
gefährlicher wesentlich tödlicher für
viele personen als die grippe und es
gibt personen die sich aus medizinischen
gründen zum beispiel nicht impfen lassen
können und an diese personen müssen
insbesondere denken und diese müssen wir
schützen genau aber dann könnte man ja
sagen wenn sich so und so viel prozent
denn bereit finden sich zu impfen dann
kann man eben möglicherweise auch die
noch sag mal mit tolerieren die jetzt
aus einfach leiblichkeit gründen sich
nicht impfen wollen weil ich meine man
muss also man muss finde ich schon
erstmal sagen in der impfung ist ein
eingriff in den körper absolut das ist
ein eingriff in den körper und dem
trainer sehr schwer zu kontrollieren da
wird sich individuell in die wolken so
ist es und zwar genau jetzt natürlich
auch mit diesen neuen impfstoffen mit
diesem m rna impfstoffen weil die eben
schon an der an der oberfläche der dna
ansetzen das ist also etwas anderes als
ich sag mal jetzt irgendwie eine andere
form von impfungen wo man eben mit toten
tieren arbeitet die ja schon auch sehr
bekannt sind das ist eine neue art der
impfung die wir so gut auch noch nicht
kennen ja das ist also das ist schon
erstmal ein eingriff und auch kein
risikofreie eingriff wie man jetzt ja
auch gesehen hat und das muss schon sehr
sehr gut begründet sein und insofern
finde ich eben auch dieses ich sag mal
so von vornherein eigentlich das
negieren überhaupt von der berechtigung
dass man da einwände haben kann und dass
man sofort jede jeder art von
impfskepsis irgendwie in einen topf
schmeißt mit verschwörungstheoretikern
und querdenkern das halte ich für einen
grundfehler dieser dieser panini ich
finde es sehr interessant weil letztlich
geht die frage ja was ist der kern einer
liberalen gesellschaft und wo setzt sie
an der philosoph christoph möllers hat
ein sehr schönes buch geschrieben
freiheitsgrade und die grundidee ist
dass es beim liberalismus immer
um körperlichkeit und zwar auch
unvernünftiger körpern inhalt sein kann
meine wille kann willkürlich sein und er
ist doch als dieser wille zu
respektieren ein beispiel wenn ich cola
trinken will macht das nicht besonders
gesund sein aber ich will nun mal cola
trinken wenn ich nach panama fahren will
brauche ich nicht einmal ein grund ich
will nach panama fahren das ist eine
freie gesellschaft und so könnte man
auch sagen mein wille mich nicht impfen
zu lassen muss in einer liberalen
intuition in gewissen grenzen unbedingt
respekt aber das ist natürlich jetzt die
schwierigkeit dass zum beispiel gebracht
das mit dem cola trinken oder panne
erfahren dass nicht andere tangiert also
das ist die frage inwiefern darf der
staat paternalistisch eingreifen um mich
zu schützen und darüber wollen wir ja
auf jeden fall auch noch sprechen
aber man kann ja auch eine andere
liberale denken nehmen nämlich
schulisches klar die amerikanisch
jüdische politologin die in ihren
büchern zum beispiel liberalismus der
furcht immer wieder auch gesagt hat es
geht nicht alleine darum das individuum
frei zu denken sondern auch die
freiheits bedingungen zu sichern damit
diese menschen überhaupt ihre freiheit
benutzen können nutzen können und
deswegen geht es bei ihr ganz klar bei
einem staat immer auch darum die
verletzlichsten zu schützen und gerade
mit ihr wurde jetzt oft für eine
impfpflicht dann eben doch argumentiert
aus liberaler warte ich möchte auch
unbedingt betonen weil sie den
persönlichen willen stark gemacht haben
und das freie handeln also wir müssen
differenzieren eben ob mein handeln nur
mich und mein eigenes wohl betrifft oder
ob mein handeln eben auch das wohl
anderer personen betrifft wenn mein
handeln nur mich betrifft und keinerlei
folgen für andere hat dann ist die
tatsache dass ich so und so handeln
möchte wahrscheinlich tatsächlich in den
allermeisten fällen ein entscheidender
grund der als anderen verbietet hier in
meinem leben einzugreifen aber wenn
meine handlung eben andere betrifft dann
ist die tatsache dass ich so und so
handeln will nicht komplett irrelevant
wie sie gesagt haben wir dürfen durchaus
andere personen auf bestimmten gefahren
aussetzen wenn für uns etwas auf dem
spiel steht aber wir dürfen
selbstverständlich auch nicht machen was
wir wollen
aber man muss natürlich sagen dass bei
näherer betrachtung diese differenz auch
gar nicht klar ist kann ich also wenn
wenn ich zum beispiel jetzt nicht nur
dieses glas trinke sondern nachher noch
eine flasche und dann noch eine flasche
und ich gehe nach hause und schlagt mein
mann
dann betrifft das eben durchaus andere
das heißt also eigentlich alle formen
von von genuss sind natürlich potenziell
auch züchter oder können ausatmen süchte
können ausatmen gewalt usw
der bis jetzt noch sehr viele andere
beispiele ganz zu schweigen kommen wir
darauf ja auch noch zu schwächen zu
sprechen von dem geschwächten
gesundheitssystem dass zu viele
fettleibige und so weiter irgendwie
auffangen muss usw also streng genommen
kann man sagen da sind wir wieder bei
dieser ursächlichen verwobenheit von ich
und anderen gibt es das eben gar nicht
also dieses ganz streng us-richter das
macht doch einen unterschied für die art
der rechtfertigung bestimmte eingriffe
in ihr leben aber rechtfertige ich
meinen eingriff in ihr leben mit ihrem
eigenen wohl weil ich sage ich möchte
ihnen helfen und deswegen schrecklich
ihre freiheit ein oder rechtfertige ich
eben mit dem wohl von anderen personen
das macht großen rechtfertigung
unterschiedlich aber ist das nicht in
die unterscheidung zwischen trotzdem ein
sehr wunder interessanter punkt dass
wenn man sich fragt was ist denn
eigentlich nur meine sache dass man
darauf nicht besonders viel kommt nach
panama zu wollen nachbarn zu fliegen ist
ökologisch überhaupt nicht mehr nur
männersache cola zu trinken weil das
ungesund ist ist gesundheits kranken
technisch nicht nur um eine sache was
wäre denn in einer sache ich meine es
ist graduell nicht wahr und da eine
absolute grenze ziehen zu wollen ist
nicht so einfach und wir beobachten ja
einen staat der diese grenze sagen wir
mal immer weiter in richtung fürsorge
verschiebt ja und trotzdem glaube ich es
ist ganz wichtig auch wenn man sagen
kann es gibt gleich fließende grenzen
ganz genau zu bleiben und ich würde
gerne john stuart mill ins spiel holen
und da ich ja sehr oft so dass man die
der referenzpunkt wenn es darum geht
liberalismus zu denken
und er sagt er ganz klar die dürfen
personen einschränken in dem was sie tun
wenn sie in dem was sie tun andere
personen schädigen und ob man nun
wirklich jede handlung die man vollzieht
zb ökonomisch so vermessen will das
waren direkt aus rechnet ob es jetzt die
schädigend auswirkt das scheint mir
wirklich ein begriff von schädigung zu
sein der einfach zu weit geht da können
wir überhaupt nicht mehr handeln da sind
wir dauernd nur noch am rechnen
also es scheint mir wichtig zu sein zum
beispiel zu überlegen muss man wirklich
eine person daran hindern jemanden aktiv
zu schädigen bewusst etwas zu tun oder
etwas zu unterlassen einer art und weise
dass man ihr die handlung
zu rechnen kann aber die unterscheidung
zwischen aktiv und bewusst und passiv
und unbewusst die ist natürlich auch gar
nicht so einfach also zum beispiel
nehmen wir zum beispiel die sind freund
der sich nicht impfen lassen möchte
das kann man ja so und so beschreiben
man kann es so beschreiben
ich habe in der letzten zeit viele
zombie filme gesehen das ist interessant
in diesem zusammenhang weil da laufen
die zombies die infizierten laufen
wirklich hoch aggressiv durch die
straßen weisen jeden tod den sie sehen
also das ist wirklich also wenn man wenn
man sozusagen so zombiefilme liest als
kollektives imaginäres oder kollektives
unbewusstes hochinteressant in bezug auf
die pandemie ja also da ist sozusagen
die infektiosität total aktiv gedacht
und so denken sie auch manche
zeitgenossen ja also jemand zum beispiel
markus gabriel hat das jüngst im
philosophie magazin so formuliert er hat
gesagt sich nicht impfen zu lassen das
kommt eigentlich der tatsache gleich
wenn ich durch die straßen rennen und
leute um rempel das ist eigentlich das
gleiche das macht man eben auch nicht so
kann man das beschreiben aber ich könnte
es ja auch anders beschreiben und sagen
wenn ich mich nicht impfen lasse ich
rempel niemanden an ich kenne jemanden
wie werde auch kein zombie sondern ich
kann ich kann mich mit schnelltests
regelmäßig testen
ich kann abstand nehmen ich kann
vorsichtig sein und so weiter also es
gibt ganz verschiedene arten von
diskreten dir jetzt nicht unterschiede
ein die uns eigentlich doch einleuchten
also jetzt tun wir irgendwie plötzlich
soeben als wäre sich nicht impfen zu
lassen das selbe wie jemandem zu laufen
fast ja das ja aber das scheint mir
jetzt sicher eine übertriebene
darstellung zu sein wir sind doch alle
denke ich sofort einer meinung das ist
was anderes ist jemanden daran zu
hindern eine andere person zum
erschießen oder sich nicht impfen zu
lassen zum beispiel das natürlich und
das ist nicht einfach nur schließen
sondern es gibt klar
schädigende handlung und böswillige
handlungen und es gibt situationen in
denen wir vielleicht nicht die beste
handlung wählen um andere zu schützen
das kann deswegen es kann trotzdem
geboten sein das zu tun weil wir zum
beispiel die pflicht zur solidarität
haben
aber es ist doch was anderes die andere
mutwillig zu schädigen
das schon aber wir müssen uns bewusst
sein eben das von uns eine gefahr
ausgeht und das ist wohl auch dann der
fall wenn wir uns bemühen uns an alle
vorgaben zu halten also wir sehen ja die
zahlen sind immer noch relativ hoch
hoch obwohl überall masten pflicht und
abstand pflicht und so weiter gilt also
der totalen schutz es auch nicht gegeben
trotz all dieser maßnahmen und es ist
natürlich nicht also sich nichts ändern
bedeutet nicht andere mutwillig und
fahrlässig zeigen zu schädigen aber doch
eben es nicht zu vermeiden dass von
einem selber diese gefahr ausgeht und
daten sagen ist als solches auch schon
problematisch dampf das dann nicht auf
mögliche trivialität zusammen existieren
ist gefährlich endet meistens tödlich
und wenn ein gewinn einer permanenten
modus dass ich bin eine mögliche gefahr
das war ja schon die ganze zeit davor
auch der fall da mussten wir von diesen
wären nicht aber wenn ich nach
australien fliegen wer weiß was ich
damit nach hinbringen ich meine die
selbstbeschreibung und auch die
adressierung des staates an mich die
kann ja nicht die ganze zeit unter
diesem sieg nun laufen was mich noch
interessieren würde ist was macht den
körper eigentlich so speziell
es gibt ja allerlei arten von gefahren
und dinge die man aber wenn es an
unseren eigenen leib gehen
da scheint er noch mal eine spezifische
grenze erinnert oder ist das auch nur
eine imaginäre grenze also erst mal ich
möchte noch mal sagen es kommt darauf an
wie groß ist das risiko was von mir aus
geht eben selbstverständlich müssen wir
immer damit leben dass von uns ein
bestimmtes risiko ausgeht also auch wenn
ich mit dem fahrrad nach hause fahren
und anderen fußgänger vorbeifahre
besteht ein gewisses risiko das ist ja
irgend einem unfall kommt aber das
risiko ist hier kleiner geringer als im
fall von corona des corona virus ist ein
tödliches virus und die die gefahr das
risiko was hier von mir aus geht jetzt
vielleicht zu groß als dass wir jetzt
einfach so in kauf nehmen dürfen
was den körper betrifft würde ich ihnen
dabei allerdings auf jeden fall recht
geben also wie sie betont haben eine
impfung vorzunehmen ist ruhig aus den
eingriff in den eigenen körper und wir
haben wahrscheinlich ein besonders
starkes recht auf leibliche
unversehrtheit also insofern müssen wir
uns schon gut überlegen sicher ob wir
das staatlich von den leuten fordern
können sich impfen zu lassen so zumal ja
also ich denke wirklich wenn man eine
impfung also es gibt ja den begriff des
volkskörpers auch noch und der
volkskörper ist der radikalen
individualisierte körper das ist der
kollektive körper das ist eben der der
der volkskörper der gesund gehalten
werden muss der ist natürlich auch
sozusagen totalitär
nationalsozialistisch über formen
man weiß und ich glaube dass in dem
augenblick wo man wirklich die die
individuelle verantwortung für den
körper preisgibt und im sinne dieses
volkskörpers argumentiert das ist eine
schiefe ebene und was man glaube ich
historisch doch sehr gut beobachten kann
und das ist ja auch mit hat mich ja auch
deutlich gezeigt dass einfach der bio
politische einsatz immer größer wird und
eben auch die grenze
die toleranzschwelle von risiken wird
immer kleiner
also wenn man das historisch sich
anguckt und die frage ist doch schon
sind wir irgendwann an einem punkt
angelangt wo eben sie haben vorhin das
wort fürsorge genannt wo fürsorge
umschlägt in paternalismus oder eben
noch viel schlimmeres also wo ist diese
grenze erreicht ich meine wenn ich mir
ansehe wie sehr wir uns jetzt gewöhnen
daran sp2 masken in zügen zu tragen und
so weiter es wird ja alles jetzt
eingeübt und so weiter ich kann mir das
schon vorstellen dass das wir im grunde
genommen nicht mehr in zügen sitzen
können ohne uns vor anderen zu
rechtfertigen ohne maske zu sitzen ja
oder das eben vielleicht dann doch wenn
jetzt angenommen es gäbe eine
impfpflicht gegen kobe 19
dass man dann in zwei drei jahren auch
über eine impfpflicht gegen grippe
spricht ich meine das schiefe ebene
argumente genau genau
darf ich vielleicht die intuition kurz
einen hohen sie nannten dynamische frau
der ist gerade auch aus anderen gründen
wieder im gespräch die müssen uns jetzt
hier nicht interessieren aber die
grundidee von coco die würde ich so
beschreiben vor 250 jahren änderte sich
in europa etwas was die beziehung des
individuums zum start an geht es für
griff der staat im zeichen des todes der
leibeigenschaft des krieges auf der ihn
auf das individuum zu dann auf einmal im
zeichen des lebens aus verboten wurden
anreize und privilegien aus drohungen
wurden versprechen und ausfahrt und aus
strafen wurde eine art von information
der polizist wurde nicht mehr vom
willkürlichen souverän geleitet sondern
vom experten der im vorgab was zu tun
ist das ist diese große transformation
die foucault biopolitik nennt er wertet
sie gar nicht er beschreibt das ja
zunächst und in diesem sinne könnte man
sagen wir sind das wäre die schafe
bedeutung in einer art schleichenden
gesundheitsdiktatur die wir aber gar
nicht merken und die uns
vielleicht sogar gut tut also bei
foucault wenn ich das richtig verstanden
habe ist ja auch immer der gedanke der
staat möchte dass ich gesund bin damit
sich effizient arbeitet er mit ich die
maschinerie kapitalismus am laufen halte
letztlich so scheint mindestens implizit
der gedanke zu sein auch zum wohle der
reichsten und mächtigsten die
profitieren eben von dieser
kapitalistischen maschinerie und das ist
natürlich eine problematische begründung
für gesundheitsfördernde maßnahmen wie
eine im rheinland derzeit zu können
müsste uns impfen damit die wirtschaft
wieder na ja aber es gibt ja also die
soziale schicht die am allermeisten
derzeit unter der pandemie leitet ist ja
die unterdessen diese menschen die am
stärksten betroffen sind von von all
diesen einschränkungen und von den
wirtschaftlichen folgen
insofern würde ich sagen wenn wir uns
jetzt bemühen das virus aus der
gesellschaft möglichst weit auszumerzen
dann geschieht das zunächst einmal auch
zugunsten dieser sozial schwächsten also
das scheint mir keine besonders
problematische form der
gesundheitsdiktatur darzustellen und man
kann vielleicht diese geschichte die
schoko erzählt positiver erzählen erst
mal und da würde ich gerne ein buch noch
reinwerfen gerade ein ganz neu
erschienenes buch von richard david
precht über die pflicht und er versucht
zu zeigen dass im grunde genommen
diese idee des staates das aus ein
reiner start der meine grundrechte
schützt also der mich davor schützt dass
der staat in die unzulässigen meine
freiheit eingreift immer schon einen
übergang drin hat oder der sich langsam
heraus gezeichnet hat in einem
fürsorgestaat und das ist durchaus auch
freundlich gemeint weil er uns nämlich
auch schützen muss und dazu gehören
immer auch so schreibt dann auch brecht
zb hygienemaßnahmen weil wir dafür
sorgen müssen dass solchen sich nicht
weiter verbreiten es gehörte dazu immer
aber auch sowas die geburtenkontrolle
sich zu überlegen wie schaffen wir es
dass mehr generationen entstehen die
diese sozialwesen mittragen und nicht
plötzlich zu viele menschen und so
weiter das heißt das was soko negativ
biopolitik nennt und das viele so
aufgenommen haben kann man auch positiv
wenden und sagen ja der staat hat auch
die aufgabe dafür zu sorgen dass es uns
gut geht aus gesellschaft also innerhalb
dieses paternalismus gedacht das könnte
man ja sagen das ist eine art und weise
sanften gut funktionierenden
paternalismus zu beschreiben der ist
sogar so gut dass wir es gar nicht
merken und er funktioniert perfekt auch
für die r
beispielsweise wir leben ja alle viel
länger wir sind alle viel gesünder
wir haben alle in diesen ländern
gesundheitsvorsorge das heißt wie auch
immer man das beschreiben es
funktioniert doch hervorragend ich würde
aber fürsorge und ungerechtfertigt
fürsorge auch von paternalismus noch
unterscheiden also materialismus ist ein
eingriff in meine eigene freiheit
zugunsten meines eigenen wohls also man
greift ihnen mein leben ein
gegen meinen willen und zwar nicht um
sich selber oder andere personen zu
bereichern sondern um mir selber zu
helfen und das würde ich sagen ist
allerdings problematisch
also wenn man ich bin eine erwachsene
persönlich finde ein autonomes wesen
wenn man gegen meinen willen in mein
leben eingreift um mir zu helfen dann
hat das etwas bevor man etwas über
griffiges das heißt allerdings angezeigt
oder ja aber es gibt das heißt nicht
wollte ich gerade sagen dass staatliche
fürsorge nicht mehr gerechtfertigt wäre
es gibt ja durchaus viele formen der
staatlichen fürsorge die wir wollen und
die wir begrüßen wir wollen die
allermeisten von uns wollen dass der
staat uns vor gewalt und willkür andere
personen schützt wir wollen dass der
staat uns güter wie straßen spitäler
schulhäuser zur verfügung stellt dass er
uns unterstützt wenn wir arbeitsunfähig
werden usw
insofern in der stadt die das tut ist
das nicht das richtige wenn wir über
politik sprechen und davon ausgehend
über fürsorgestaat sprechen wir
natürlich über den körper und über
gesundheit über hygiene und so weiter
und da stellt sich schon die frage wie
viel davon wollen die ja und ganz viel
wird paternalistisch gerechtfertigt also
fett und zucker steuern wurden
angesprochen
verbote von von tabak zum beispiel oder
alkohol an jüngere menschen aber auch
viele andere dinge als ein gutes
beispiel für dich immer dem die
helmtragepflicht für motorradfahrer
da gibt es natürlich viele die sagen
würden ja erst einmal ist es natürlich
die pflicht des staates nicht zu
informieren mir also zu sagen hör mal zu
wenn du motorrad fährst und keinen helm
trägt dann riskierst du ein schweres
schütteltrauma zu erleiden ganz schlimme
folgen für dich deswegen tag doch einen
hellen wenn ich dann aber sage ich
möchte das aber nicht dieses
freiheitsgefühl auf dem motorrad ist mir
dieses risiko wert dann stellt sich die
frage darf der stadt trotzdem sagen und
du fährst nicht ohne helm durch die
straßen
thomas pohlack nicht mal interessieren
was sie davon halten
sieht doch ein trägerin beim firma gegen
meinen willen also ich würde tatsächlich
beim fahrradfahren ich war kein motorrad
aber fahrrad ich würde eigentlich keinen
helm tragen
ich tue das mein mann zu lieben weil die
große sorgen macht und weil ich sehr
viel fahrrad fahren durch berlin
deshalb trage ich einen helm aber nicht
eigentlich nicht wirklich aus eigener
überzeugung und da spielt natürlich
irrationalität hinein ja weil ich weiß
natürlich dass eigentlich ein helm gut
ist und dass er mich im zweifelsfalle
schützt ich habe auch zwei kinder usw
aber ich eben stichwort der wind in den
haaren das ist schon ein lebensgefühl
ich bin immer seitdem ich klein bin
fahrrad gefahren und immer ohne helm und
immer sehr riskant und das ist für mich
ein freiheitsgefühl und das ist insofern
ist das schon ein opfer dass ich da
bringe und das ist sogar ganz das ist
aber eine sehr interessante frage beim
motorradfahrer stellt sich die frage
natürlich noch viel viel brisanter aber
ich wollte für ihn noch eine andere
sache sagen nämlich stichwort fürsorge
paternalismus wir haben die ganze zeit
davon geredet dass der staat eingreift
um uns irgendwie gesundheit einzuimpfen
im wahrsten sinne des wortes aber
interessanterweise sind die individuen
ihr heutzutage auch bereit sich selber
kontrollieren zu lassen und zwar durch
kleine geräte die wir alle dabei tragen
also stichwort konnte verzerrt das heißt
also wir sind immer mehr eigentlich
bereit dazu unsere daten wie viel habe
ich mich bewegt wie viel habe ich
geschlafen wie lange bin ich geschockt
und so weiter wie es meine herzfrequenz
das alles irgendwie outsourcen an
irgendwelche clouds an irgendwelche
unternehmen die irgendwas damit machen
also insofern bestes wollen das muss man
ja schon dazu sagen das ist ja explizit
die message von von diesen großkonzernen
da könnte man sagen
foucaults beschreibung ist insofern noch
brisanter als es gar nicht mehr um den
start geht sondern als ist ein viel
größeres feld der kooperativen genau
oder faktischen überwachung der arbeitet
genau das hat von korea in seinem denken
drin das ist die selbstdisziplinierung
also das heißt wir brauchen gar kein
überwacher mehr sondern wir haben diesen
überwacher eigentlich so sehr
internalisiert wobei natürlich konnte
verzerrt so eine interessante so
zwitterwesen ist weil einerseits ich
benutze diese dinger freiwillig ich
finde es super die zu benutzen also ich
persönlich nicht aber ich spreche jetzt
mal für so jemanden
auf der anderen seite haben wir
natürlich durch diese geräte unser
gewissen wiederum extern avisiert also
wir tragen das gewissen eigentlich in
unserer hosentasche und es ist faktisch
nicht unseres sondern eines und das ist
jetzt wichtig eines was ja objektivierte
daten sozusagen einspeist also man über
ich ist sozusagen nicht meint sondern
ein qualifiziertes über ich so dass ich
in meiner tasche trage und da finde ich
kommt wirklich etwas rein was glaube ich
ganz wichtig ist nämlich der unterschied
zwischen körper und leib also der körper
eben als etwas was quantifizierbar ist
messbar ist und so weiter ich kann die
größe messen das gewicht alles mögliche
und der leib phänomenologische gesehen
ist ja ist ja sozusagen meine
leiblichkeit die ich selber spüren
und der begriff der leiblichkeit selbst
eben voraus und das hat finde ich ganz
viel auch mit verantwortung zu tun also
mit mündigkeit auch zu tun selbst voraus
dass ich ein verhältnis zu meinem leib
habe dass ich ihn spüre dass ich weiß
was zudem gut was sie tun nicht so gut
und das müsste ich mich an irgendwelchen
daten oder irgendwem der mir sagt ich
muss aber pro tag fünf kilometer laufen
was für ein schwachsinn ist entzieht
sich der krebs tage an denen will ich
nicht laufen aber jetzt haben wir glaube
ich ganz ganz viele verschiedene punkte
auf dem tisch es erstens war glaube ich
kann man an dieser stelle sehr gut noch
die jungs schon rein bringen weil diese
ganze beschreibung jetzt die
leistungsgesellschaft in der das ich
sozusagen unbewusst nicht einmal mehr
wirklich selbstbewusst mit schwimmt in
diesem grund die schweiz selbst
geschichten und sich auf messen lästig
taxieren lässt sich anweisungen geben
lässt
das ist eigentlich das was du tun meint
mit seiner idee dieser überwachten die
die internalisiert haben nur und das
scheint mir wirklich ein unterschied zu
sein es macht doch ein unterschied ob
das der staat ist oder private firmen
also sie haben jetzt gesagt das ist
eigentlich sogar noch schlimmer ist die
steigerung oder du hast das gesagt ich
finde es ist ein großer unterschied weil
ich doch noch selber entscheiden kann
kaufe ich so ein gerät und beschreibe
ich dass da währenddessen ich schon
finde ein staatswesen das hat das
gefälligst zu unterlassen also das
möchte ich nicht dass der staat
plötzlich sagt ich müsste jetzt wenn ich
eine krankenversicherung abschließen
müsste ich da diese daten liefern
aber all diese maßnahmen die sie erwähnt
haben zuckersteuer vielleicht auch
helmpflicht lassen sich ja nicht nur
paternalistisch rechtfertigen sondern
wir können sie haben das vorhin ganz
kurz angedeutet dass auch mit anderen
rechtfertigung formen begründen zb leben
verursachen krankheiten verursacht
übergewicht auch viele kosten die dann
andere personen mit tragen müssten
könnten also ein gerechtigkeit argument
anführen und sagen das ist ungerecht
wenn ich selber ungesund leben dadurch
kosten für andere verursacher also diese
zuckersteuer zum beispiel nicht als
schutz der konsumentinnen sondern als
gerechtigkeit grund anderen personen
gegenüber die sonst die kosten tragen
würden bei diesem argument bin ich
allerdings nicht ganz sicher ob es
funktioniert das ist nämlich nicht ganz
klar ob zum beispiel übergewicht
tatsächlich insgesamt mehrkosten
verursacht also es ist klar die
empirische frage keine frage also weil
übergewichtige personen verursachen
klarerweise höhere der apa und
heizkosten wer so lange sie am leben
sind aber sie sterben auch früher
ich glaube ein anderes argument es
vielleicht fast entscheidende zum
beispiel anzusetzen bei der
verantwortung der produzentinnen und der
verkäuferinnen also wir könnten sagen
das moralisch nicht problematisch sich
selber zu schaden es ist allerdings
moralisch problematisch anderen personen
zu ermöglichen oder sie dabei zu
unterstützen sich selber zu schaden also
das macht noch ein großer unterschied ob
ich sage ich darf gewisse dinge nicht
tun weil ich sonst andere leute schädige
aber noch einmal mein beispiel mit
eigenen gewehr um laufen oder ob ich
mich selber als das haben wir mal
kostenfaktor dauernd vermessen und dauer
und überlege kostet vielleicht zu viel
ist vielleicht mein konsumverhalten so
dass ich eine last bin für die anderen
ich möchte nicht in einer gesellschaft
leben in der wir so aufeinander das
wirklich das ist doch eine erbärmliche
art und weise aufeinander zu blicken
sollten wir damit nicht einfach aufhören
und interessant ist ja dass dieses erst
mal sehr solidarisch argument was ich
jetzt mal nachvollziehen kann zu sagen
wenn ich mich um gesund ernähre dann bin
ich ein kostenfaktor für die
gesellschaft dann belastet ich sozusagen
diese die gemeinschaft das ist ja so
inbegriff irgendwie von solidarität das
dann eben nicht zu tun und so weiter
aber die kehrseite ist natürlich dass
genau diese argumentation eine
knallharte und utilitaristische
argumentation ist eben keine kann tische
die ontologische in dem sinne dass man
sagt jeder mensch hat eine würde zu der
auch gehört dass ich mich selber
entscheiden kann wie ich lebe das ist
kann tja das ist mündigkeit ich gebe mir
selbst mein gesetz
während ihrer argumentation eigentlich
darauf hinaus läuft eben ich muss
ständig in einem kosten nutzen kalkül
sein also ich muss ständig sozusagen
meine handlungen in beziehung setzen zum
zum/zur zum kollektiven glück also mein
glück wird immer in relation gesetzt und
kollektiven glück und es ist immer eine
abrechnungs frage und das ist
knallharter und ich würde ich sagen dass
es in tourismus ist es geht um
gerechtigkeit also es ist eine form der
ungerechtigkeit wenn die kosten
verursache und sie müssen dafür gerade
stehen sie müssen wir diese kosten
aufkommt ist einfach ungerecht ich bin
auch mit ihnen einverstanden
gerechtigkeit ist nicht das einzige was
uns wichtig sein sollte in einer
gesellschaft es sollte uns auch ein
ideal der solidarität oder der
mitmenschlichkeit nichtig sein was
bedeutet dass wir jetzt nicht jeden
rappen zweimal umdrehen und haargenau
ausrechnen wer kostet wie so viele die
gleiche voraussetzungen haben und
gegebenheit hier sind einfach nicht alle
gleich schnell gleich dick wenn sie
gleich viel essen das ist eigentlich
eine ganz große unfairness da wäre ich
immer dafür tolerant zu sein und
trotzdem also wenn am ende auch
ökonomisch schwächer gestellte den
teuren lebensstil von reicheren personen
mit finanzieren dann hat das etwas
ungerechtes und etwas worüber wir
durchaus diskutieren
da sind intuition miteinander im kampf
ich will noch einen weiteren intuition
kampf ins spiel bringen es gibt ja das
sogenannte matching was ist damit
gemeint aufgrund der verhaltensökonomie
hat man herausgefunden dass menschen
dazu geneigt sind sich rationaler zu
verhalten wenn man die entscheidungs
konstellation ein bisschen vor
bearbeitet wenn man ihnen sagt ich gebe
den vier auswahlmöglichkeiten sondern
zwei und die eine ist vielleicht
attraktiver präsentiert oder wirkt
intuitiver dieses nation zeigt sich in
ganz ganz vielen dingen zum beispiel
auch bei ernährung hinweisen und vielen
anderen dingen
das heißt der staat gibt gewisse
rahmenbedingungen vor die einen dazu
bringen sich selbst was das dann auch
heißen mag dafür zu entscheiden dass
vernünftige zu tun das wäre wenn ich sie
jetzt richtig verstehe eine art sanfter
paternalismus weil man die mündigkeit
die man eigentlich zugesteht nimmt indem
er die entscheidungs konstellation in
der man überhaupt möglich werden könnte
schon so vor konstruiert hat dass es
eigentlich nur noch eine vernünftige
entscheidung geben kann
also ich würde den matches so definieren
nacho und das heißt deutlich stutzte sie
zu einer bestimmten handlungen wenn ich
ihre entscheidungssituation so gestaltet
dass sie nach wie vor alle
handlungsoptionen haben dass sie aber
gegeben vor allem rationale aspekte der
menschlichen psychologie geneigt sind
einen bestimmten nämlich diese bestimmte
handlung zu wählen ein klassisches
beispiel ist produktplatzierung im
supermarkt dass es stellt sich heraus
menschen sind eher geneigt die produkte
zu kaufen die auf augenhöhe platziert
sind nicht jenen die versteckt unten im
regal liegen
das heißt wenn ich die karotten auf
augenhöhe platziere und die schokoriegel
zum beispiel wurde die zucker getränke
und verstecke dann haben sie nach wie
vor beide optionen aber gegeben die
menschliche psychologie werden sind
statistisch gesehen mehr karotten
grauwerte manipuliert wohlwollen es wird
manchmal gesagt dass das eine form der
manipulation darstellung dass es
vielleicht auch richtig also
manipulation manipulierer sie hin zu
einer bestimmten handlung wenn ich sie
dazu bringen diese handlung zu tun aber
mit mittel die ihre vernunft umgehen und
das tue ich natürlich wenn ich zum
beispiel auf diese psychologische
tendenz abhebe die vorhinein gesprochen
habe es ist allerdings auch schwer zu
vermeiden nicht ich muss ja im
supermarkt irgendetwas auf augenhöhe
platzieren und sobald mir bewusst ist
dass das ihre kaufentscheidung mit
beeinflussen wird kann ich sozusagen
diese sanfte form der manipulation nicht
mehr vermeiden ich glaube was uns eher
stört an diesem paternalistischen formen
des matching ist schlicht und ergreifend
die tatsache dass eine paternalistische
motivation dahinter steht also wir
wollen manchmal einfach nicht dass
andere personen irgendwie versuchen uns
zu helfen wollen vielleicht manchmal
eher dass die verkäuferin im laden auf
ihr eigenes wohl schaut als dass wir uns
dass wir auf unser wunsch haben wir
versucht uns menschen glaube ich dachte
ein philosoph mal so schön gesagt maybe
you're right but we made you boss also
vielleicht hast du recht aber wir hatten
eigentlich zum chef gemacht
aber was ich schon sehr interessant sind
ja an diesem an dieser diskussion ist
dass sarah konlé eine philosophie ja
sagt vielleicht ist harter paternalismus
also ein knallhartes verbot die in
mexiko ist gibt es ist gekränkt getränke
einfach nicht mehr zu kaufen für kinder
vielleicht sogar schwerer ist als diese
najin geschichten weil eben nothing ist
leicht manipulativ und möglicherweise
nicht einmal effektiv genug
währenddessen ein verbot
wir wissen es ist uns verboten ist das
nicht so
eine art dunkle konsequenz wir wollen
keine mündigkeit und wir stehen auch
dazu deswegen ist das besser ist es
nicht minder zu wissen es ist mir etwas
verboten worden als nie so recht zu
wissen wo ich manipuliert worden bin
ist denn mündigkeit nicht genau die
fähigkeit die eigenen manipulations
anstrengungen zu durchschauen und sich
gegebenenfalls der rechten bewegung
schaut also ich würde ich werde mit
diesem begriff auch so ein bisschen
meine probleme weil ich erst mal sagen
würde kapitalismus heißt nothing
generell sowieso immer schon werbung usw
das ist alles läuft alles so gut an also
wir werden ständig manipulieren in
unseren auf entscheidungen
ich werde auch im liebesleben irgendwie
manipuliert ich werde verführt und so
weiter also naja oder ich war aber es
gibt noch freie entscheidung fällt noch
weiß ja nicht jede entscheidung über den
ich meine ja nur ich meine ja nur da
auch da würde ich fragen wie wo ist
jetzt genau die grenze also ist nicht
einfach und ich würde ihn jetzt nämlich
eigentlich zustimmen heimberger das war
meine absicht gewesen immer schon
irgendwie in manipulations verhältnissen
drin also insofern leuchtet mir das
argument gar nicht so richtig ein und
saar conley argumentiert letztlich
natürlich auch konsequenz ist also ihr
schlagendes argument ist letztlich auch
nichts es nützt mir wenn mir knallharte
für boote erlassen
und da würde ich allerdings schon auch
sagen dann dabei bleiben das ist eben
problematisch wenn andere personen
zugunsten meines eigenen wohls in mein
leben eingreifen das heißt nicht dass
paternalismus immer verboten ist also
wenn eine person nicht autonom genug ist
oder wenn bei dem angriff für die person
hinreichen viel auf dem spiel steht dann
halten müssen uns auch gerechtfertigt
sein
also stellen wir uns vor eine einen mann
wurde kürzlich von seiner freundin
verlassen und stürzt sich jetzt im nebel
seiner verzweiflung von der brücke oder
will sich von der brücke stürzen hier
haben wir eine pflicht würde ich sagen
einzugreifen
warum ja einerseits ist die person nicht
vollständig autonomen sie handelt im
nebel der gegenwärtigen verzweiflung und
andererseits steht enorm viel auf dem
spiel nämlich das ganze leben dieses
mannes aber bei er zuckersteuer zum
beispiel würde ich sagen ja auf
bestimmte weise handeln auch viele
erwachsene personen die zucker
konsumieren selbst bestimmen und das
steht nicht ihr ganzes leben auf dem
spiel
ich habe mir da viel
unproblematischer zum beispiel eben der
verkauf solcher produkte an kinder zu
verbieten mal kinder in der relevanten
hinsicht noch nicht ist doch der punkt
in mexiko oder freund erklärend sagen in
mexiko in einem bundesstaat von mexiko
ist der verkauf an fastfood und von
softgetränken also sehr zu bereichen
getränke an kinder unter einer gewissen
altersgrenze verboten und da hat ja sehr
viel mit möglichkeit zu tun wenn man
davon ausgeht dass die entscheidungs
souveränität ab einem gewissen alter
erst ein anderes mit den kindern und ich
habe auch da würde ich nochmal stichwort
leiblichkeit sagen worauf wir doch als
gesellschaft viel mehr achten sollten
jetzt anstatt über verbote und
übernachtung zu reden ist darauf
wirklich auch eben so was wie geschmack
zu schulen also und da wundere ich mich
zum beispiel dass gerade an schulen das
essen ungenießbar ist also unsere
tochter ist nicht mehr in der schule
weil es ungenießbar ist man kann dieses
kantine essen nicht essen
aber wichtig ja das heißt also es geht
doch es geht doch schon darum eben was
heißt es denn mich in meiner
leiblichkeit in irgendeiner form
verantwortungsvoll zu bewegen mich zu
ihr zu verhalten heißt doch eben auch zu
genau zu kennen was tut mir gut was tut
mir nicht gut und darauf viel mehr wert
zu legen dass wir die eigene autonomie
unmündigkeit eben auch in dieser
hinsicht schulen finde ich viel
wichtiger als darüber so wie man
sozusagen wenn das kind schon in den
brunnen gefallen ist wie wir dann
irgendwie rum zuckeln können damit
wieder auf den richtigen weg kommt ja
ein guter punkt ich glaube es gibt noch
eine andere überlegen wie die haben wir
noch gar nicht gesprochen und ich finde
ich ebenso wichtig nämlich sich mal zu
überlegen was ist eigentlich das ziel
auf das wir paternalistisch oder
matching mäßig unterwegs sind und die
gesellschaft verbessern wollen wir haben
schon gesagt das eine kann sein den
menschen irgendwie zu schützen ihm zu
ermöglichen ein gutes leben zu leben und
das andere kann sein eine möglichst
glückliche gesunde fette gute
gesellschaft zu haben
und bei beiden dingen würde ich sagen
das problem ist halt das manchmal gar
nicht so klar ist ob wir alle genau die
gleichen wertvorstellungen haben worin
eigentlich ein gutes leben besteht und
das ist auch ein punkt den chance die
will immer wieder deutlich gemacht hat
dass er gesagt hat wir sind keine
stromlinienförmige gesellschaft wir
brauchen sogar exzentriker wir brauchen
menschen die aus der reihe tanzen
und da gibt es vielleicht welche
die genießen ihr leben gerne in form
zügen in form wissen warum das die
lebensjahre verlieren werden um das
scheint mir schon wichtig zu sein dass
man so leben darf schon dass wir nicht
plötzlich den eindruck haben ist muss
alles auf diese verlängerung eines
dritten gesunden lebens hinauslaufen und
pasta wirklich jetzt in der pandemie
auch eine diskussion die wieder neu
aufgekommen ist also müssen die denn
alle unbedingt so lang leben zu alt
werden es gibt es gibt ja im
schweizerischen diesen wahnsinnig schön
begriff der freiheit ja so eine liberale
kunden finde man sollte das erweitern
durch die frei sinnlichkeit denn es ist
nicht alles sinnvoll es ist auch manches
sinnlich und der exzess das
unvernünftige auch die wegen mir die
zwölf sneakers am abend das kann ja auch
zur lebensqualität in einer sehr
verqueren weise nein zu sagen also frau
hast du jetzt jetzt gebe ich ihn mögen
sie eine vorlage frage wofür es sich zu
leben lohnt das leben ist ja kein
marathonlauf dass derjenige gewinnt am
ende noch steht sondern es hat höhen und
tiefen und das absolut ungesunde und
unvernünftige markiert meistens doch
höhen
ja aber ich glaube dass also wenn man
jetzt und das ist wirklich eine
interessante frage was ist das gute
leben ich würde sagen das hat wiederum
ganz viel mit nur nichts zu tun
das gute leben kann kann sich darin
gestalten dass ich an einem abend warum
auch immer zwölf sneakers oder andere
kriegs oder unbedingt braucht und das
ist mir wahnsinnig gut warum auch immer
aber ich muss innerlich so frei sein
dass ich das nicht zur regel machen und
so weiter also sozusagen ich muss ich
muss innerlich so frei sein dass ich
eben punktuell sagen kann ich brauche
den access ich brauche die ekstase und
dann aber eben wieder auch in andere
modi zurück schalten kann also dieser
wechsel zwischen modi das scheint mir
doch glaube ich zum guten leben
unbedingt dazu zu gehören und das ist
auch schulung glaube ich oder ich würde
vielleicht die innere freiheit noch
anderes definieren
ich muss vielleicht doch dabei bleiben
mich verstehen zu können als auf kunde
reagierend und das kann natürlich gründe
geben für für ungesundes verhalten mit
ich es ist durchaus etwas wertvolles
verbunden ich weiß nicht mit alkohol
trinken und dem spaß
was damit einhergeht und dann habe ich
gründe dafür aber wenn ich nicht mehr
handle
als reaktion auf bestimmte gründe
sondern ich hatte zum beispiel getrieben
von einem wal oder getrieben von einer
sucht dann verliere ich die
selbstkontrolle dann verliere ich die
autonomie und dann ist vielleicht auch
das gute leben in gefahr übrigens aber
in beide richtungen also es gibt ja es
gibt ja auch einen 1 genießen des
mangels
also es ist ja nicht nur ein es gibt ja
nicht nur ein genießen der fülle im
sinne von ich fresse zwar schnitt uns
nicht als in mich rein sondern es gibt
auch ein genießen des mangels also von
kafkas hungerkünstler über bestimmte
simon wayne ist natürlich auch ein
berühmtes beispiel also sozusagen man
kann eben die diät auch zwanghaft machen
auch das gesund sein wollen kann einen
zwang entwickeln ich glaube auch dass
dieses quantitativ phänomen dazu führt
dass gesundheit tatsächlich auch etwas
extrem zwanghaftes kriegt nur weil man
eben diesen externen beobachter hat er
mich ständig mit objektiven kriterien
misst und man man man kann sozusagen
ohne dieses gerät irgendwann gar nicht
mehr so gesundheit suchen krankheitsbild
dass wir uns nicht vorstellen könne ja
absolut
und jetzt haben ja die ganze zeit
darüber gesprochen dass wir sozusagen
unser verhalten anpassen sollten wegen
unserer selbst weiß nie was am abend
nicht gesund sind oder wie viel sie
völlig aus der luft gegriffen aber auch
weil hier so lang sein wollen also mit
bezug auf die impfung zum beispiel haben
wir gesagt na ja vielleicht gibt's ja
wirklich gute gründe sich impfen zu
lassen nicht nur meinetwegen sondern zu
uns der anderen nun könnte man die
gedanken weiterspinnen und sagen na ja
das geht nicht nur ums behaupten es geht
auch um den eigenen körper also gibt es
nicht auch gute gründe zu sagen ich
sollte blutspenden ich sollte
knochenmarkspenden ich sollte allenfalls
meine eine niere spenden ich habe mir
noch eine zweite
also können wir auch ein imperativ in
diese richtung stricken und sagen fertig
mit körperlichen grenzen auch davon
müssen die reichlich abgeben ich
prinzipiell scheint mir das durchaus
möglich das wird manchmal gesagt mein
körper gehört mir das ist aus mehreren
gründen eine unglückliche formulierung
zunächst einmal besteht zwischen mir und
meinem körper nicht einfach einen
eigentumsverhältnisse dass ich mein
körper besitzt so wie ich mein hemd
besitze
gemeint ist damit wohl ich kann mit
meinen körper tun was ich will aber das
scheint mir eben auch falsch wenn ich
unter umständen einer anderen person das
leben retten könnte indem ich teile
meines körpers hergebe dann stellt sich
absolut die frage ob ich nicht eine
pflicht habe das zu tun wenn ich zum
beispiel die ihr leben retten könnte
dadurch dass ich meine haare abschneidet
dann habe ich wohl die pflicht das zu
tun
es gibt allerdings doch noch wenig sagen
ein unterschied zwischen einer möglichen
pflicht zur organspende und einer
allfälligen pflicht sich impfen zu
lassen
zunächst einmal ist es ein kategorialen
unterschied also wenn wir uns impfen
dann verhindern wir dadurch dass wir
anderen personenschaden zum beispiel sie
infizieren mit einer krankheit wenn wir
organe spenden dann helfen wir dadurch
anderen personen indem wir ihn im
lebenswichtige organe zur verfügung
stände ich würde sagen grundsätzlich
sind unsere nicht schädigung pflichten
wesentlich stärker als unsere pflichten
haben könnte sein die haben eine
impfpflicht aber nicht eben eine
fließende materialien zu spenden darf
ich mal so einen dritten fall werden wir
einer trinkenden menschen im see sie
dann würde man ja auch sagen es gibt
eine hilfs pflicht war das eminent
überlebens sichert ist das ist ja bei
organspenden tatsächlich eher der fall
es ist eine ganz konkrete überlebens
pflicht und könnte man da nicht
moralisch mir würde es schwer fallen
aber ich könnte den weg sehen sein
eigentlich hat jeder der zwei nieren hat
tendenziell moralische pflicht eine zu
spenden für die menschen die sonst
sterben also ob wir eine pflicht haben
einer anderen person zu helfen hängt ja
immer auch davon ab wie viel es uns
kostet eben wenn ich ihr leben retten
kann indem ich irgendwohin 10 franken
spende dann habe ich eine pflicht das zu
tun meine ich wenn ich mein eigenes
leben aufs spiel setzen muss um ihr
leben zu retten dann habe ich keine
pflicht das zu tun und jetzt stellt sich
die frage was stellen die kosten da wenn
ich ihnen einen ihre spende und diese
sind sicher nicht geringer also meine
eigene lebenserwartung wird damit
verringert das ist ein massiver eingriff
in sofern ist sicher hier die frage ob
ich nun pflicht haben könnte das zu tun
ja also ich bin noch kein
ersatzteillager ich habe eine würde und
meine würde ist unantastbar und dass
wenn wir das preisgeben also da wo
kommen wir da hin ja also da würde ich
also da würde ich sofort sagen stopp
nein also da wird's wirklich auch und
selbst bei der organspende finde ich
muss man schon wirklich auch genauer
hinsehen es gibt sehr viele gute gründe
zu sagen
ich werde organspenderin also im falle
eines schweren unfalls habe ich einen
auswahl so und dann noch aber man muss
schon sich auch darüber im klaren sein
dass wenn man organspenderin oder
spender ist dass man dann in jedem fall
auch lebensverlängernde maßnahmen
sozusagen bejahen muss ja also das heißt
ich kann dann keine patientenverfügung
aufsetzen und sagen im falle eines
schweren unfalls lasst mich bitte sofort
sterben ich will nicht dass mir
irgendwie geholfen mit weil dann wenn
wir organe entnommen werden dann muss
ich schon irgendwie noch warm sein ja
also da muss man ein vegetatives system
schon noch irgendwie funktionieren und
das muss man schon bewusst wollen ja
insofern finde ich eben auch die diese
diskussion um die widerspruchslösung das
ist eine diskussion die geführt wird
also die besagt dass man wenn man nicht
zu lebzeiten widerspricht willich man
automatisch darin ein da gerade an
diskussion in der schweiz und wechselt
von erweiterte zustimmungslösung auf
widerspruch genau heißt daneben dass
wenn ich zu lebzeiten nicht
widersprochen habe ich dann eben im
falle eines schweren unfalls automatisch
organspenderin werde
und aus meiner sicht ist das ethisch
nicht zu rechtfertigen und zwar genau
deshalb weil man weil man aktiv bejahen
muss man muss das bejahen aktiv also das
argument für die widerspruchslösung ist
ja immer die trägheit ja also ich bin
irgendwie zu träge um irgendwie mich zu
kümmern und so weiter das könnte man
aber ganz leicht aushebeln indem man
sozusagen meinetwegen die vergabe eines
führerscheins oder eines
personalausweises koppelt immer an die
frage wenn man da auf dem abend sowieso
sitzt dass dann jemand der sitzung fragt
hören sie mal wie stehen sie denn zur
organspende und wollen sie das gerne
machen oder nicht dann kann ich mich
bewusst mit dieser frage
auseinandersetzen
aber ich muss mich damit
auseinandersetzen weil es eine ethisch
sehr sehr diffizile frage ist und weil
es eben wirklich im grunde sehr tief
eingreift in mein selbstverständnis weil
ich dann eben zum beispiel keine
patientenverfügung haben kann
die ganz klar lebensverlängernde
maßnahmen ablehnt gut aber wir könnten
ja also wenn du jetzt über über diese
frage von zustimmungslösung oder
widerspruchslösung sprechen wollen ich
wollte nur noch ganz kurz anfingen
vorhin so habe ich das verstanden haben
wie über die moralische pflicht
gesprochen organe zu spenden nicht um
eine allfällige staatliche pflicht das
mehr organe entnommen werden liegen
davon möchte ich auch extrem wichtig
weil diese in unser mut zu sagen dass
ich dann ich als ersatzteillager ist
natürlich sehr oft so in bildern
gesprochen dass der staat norwegen die
plötzlich kommt diese möglichkeit die
die beschriebenen haben dass wir
personen dazu bringen sich damit
auseinanderzusetzen das haben wir auch
bei der widerspruchslösung also wir
können ja auch wir müssen unbedingt auch
bei der widerspruchslösung dafür sorgen
dass allen absolut klar ist dass wenn
sie keinen widerspruch anmelden das dann
ihre organe entnommen werden können wir
müssen unbedingt dafür sorgen dass es
keine allzu hohen kosten bedeutet diesen
widerspruch anzumelden also im idealfall
einfach nur ein klick mit der maus und
dann habe ich widerspruch angemeldet und
meine organe können nicht entnommen
werden
aber wenn das der fall ist dann sehe ich
nicht warum es problematisch sein sollte
diese widerspruchslösung einzuführen
noch mal ist es sterben derzeit personen
weil weil ihnen die organe fädeln und
diese personen sterben manchmal nicht
deswegen weil sich menschen bewusst
gegen eine organspende entschieden haben
sondern eben einfach weil sie sich nie
mit dieser frage auseinandergesetzt
haben oder weil sie zu faul waren sich
fünf minuten zeit zu nehmen aber nicht
im register einzutragen weil das scheint
mir schon empörend dass wieder tote in
kauf nehmen zusagen aus bequemlichkeit
haben wir zuerst gesprochen über die
leben dort spende und jetzt sprechen wir
über die post mortem spende und da
kommen ja noch ganz viele dinge dazu wie
zum beispiel wie definieren wir
überhaupt den todeszeitpunkt ist das
eine naturwissenschaftliche definition
oder gibt es da mehr so metaphysische
vorstellung die mitschwingen gibt so was
die religionsfreiheit dass ich mich auch
nicht dazu äußern muss und so weiter
wenn wir aber noch einmal beim bei dem
bei dem vergleich bleiben ich werde dann
kann man ja auch sagen warum wenn man
argumentiert es sterben im moment leute
weiß ich kein organ kriegen es sterben
auch leute weil sich kein knochenmark
kriegen und das könnten wir alle jetzt
spenden warum denken wir denn da nicht
dass wir uns gegenseitig darauf
aufmerksam machen sollten also eben
etwas scheint mir da schief zu sein wir
tun gerade meine meinung meinen gefühlen
auch ein bisschen so als wäre es völlig
klar wir müssen hier solidarisch sein
und ganz viel können wir voneinander
moralisch gesehen verlangen
aber eigentlich ist es mir nicht so klar
ich bin nicht sicher ob dieser übergang
trägt und zwar deshalb weil es den tod
als eine endgültigkeit betrifft die
vielfach
kulturell überlagert ist und die
natürlich auch unser leibes verständnis
betrifft kein körper kommt und war zu
einem jahr es immer kulturell überlagert
und das interessante an der organspende
ist ja dass der leib auch als toter noch
als leib betrachtet wird man darf wird
einem nicht alles tun die person ist
gleichsam noch da obwohl sie liegen da
als entscheidende als selbstbestimmte
als autonome person da ist und man darf
auch nicht sagen man darf nicht
vergessen sagt kommen zonen ins spiel
die mit der vernunft nur so ganz schwer
anzukratzen sind zum beispiel die frage
nach dem jenseits
nach einer körperlichen unversehrtheit
nach dem tod
und da sind ja nun sagen wir grundwerte
und grundentscheidungen betroffenen die
ans herz dessen geben was ein freier
staat überhaupt sein soll
selbstverständlich deswegen sollte
unbedingt auch jeder jede die
möglichkeit haben eben diesen
widerspruch anzumelden also wenn ich
wenn es meine religiöse überzeugung ist
dass meine seele auch oder meine seele
in irgendeiner weise noch in meinem
körper gebunden ist dass es aus
religiösen gründen problematisches
meinem körper organe zu entnehmen
dann muss ich unbedingt die freiheit
haben diesen widerspruch anzumelden dann
ist es staatlich es gibt gruppen die
sagen das geht überhaupt gar nicht es
gibt kein eingriff 0
das würde ich durchaus auch sehen wenn
es für ein personen eine tiefe religiöse
überzeugung ist dass sie sich nicht
impfen lassen kann aus welchen gründen
auch immer dann würde ich sagen bedeutet
für diese person enorm hohe kosten sich
zu impfen und das müssen wir
respektieren und von so einer person
könnten wir vielleicht nicht verlangen
können wir wohl nicht verlangen dass sie
sich impft genauso wie von einer person
die eine allergische reaktion zum
beispiel haben würde auf die impfung so
dass auch in griechenland wenn das denn
das ein argument ist um zu sagen wir
gehen zurück zum anfang des gesprächs
und es ist so dass der freund am anfang
hervorkam eine solche tiefe überzeugung
kommt dass er sich nicht impfen lassen
kann nicht impfen lassen denn dann
würden ja gleichsam wenn wir sagen es
gibt die moralische pflicht sich impfen
zu lassen solche personen zwingen genau
alle diese dinge zu äußern
und da habe ich schon irgendwie stück
weit meine schwierigkeit weil ich denke
dass ist doch eigentlich auch privat
sache die man über solche dinge besser
gewesen sondern hätten auch nicht
privatsache es betrifft mich unter
umständen sterben ich kein organ kriege
da darf ich doch vielleicht von ihnen
kurz verlangen dass sie sich dazu äußern
warum sie nicht mein leben retten wenn
sie dann sagen hören sie ist meine
religiöse überzeugung dass ich das nicht
tun möchte dann reicht das schon als
rechtfertigung aber sozusagen die idee
sie brauchen sich überhaupt nicht mir
gegenüber zu werden warum sie mich
sterben lassen das würde ich kritisch
sehen
ich glaube nur ganz viele würden
kritisch sehen dass man überhaupt kein
organ spenden gleichsetzen kann nicht
sterben lassen
da sind wir alle mörder jemand nicht zu
retten ist natürlich nicht dasselbe wie
ihn zu töten es gibt aber menschen die
so argumentieren auch in der philosophie
das wissen sie ja schon die würden sagen
na ja im prinzip ist das unterlassene
hilfeleistung sie ich vorhin gesagt hab
ich glaube es besteht ein unterschied
zwischen unseren jedes pflichten und
unser nicht schädigung pflichten und
erstere sind stärker deswegen diesmal
etwas schlimmeres als aber die ist denn
eigentlich wird werde ich jetzt zum
beispiel eine patientenverfügung habe in
der ganz klar drin steht ich will keine
lebensverlängernde maßnahmen will ich
nicht und ich habe jetzt aber nicht die
sinne diesen widerspruch eingelegt gegen
die organspende
dann besteht da ja irgendwie ein
widerspruch also in sich ja weil beides
geht halt nicht also man kann mir nicht
organe entnehmen wenn ich aber in dieser
patientenverfügung dargelegt habe dass
ich keine lebensverlängernde maßnahmen
will was gilt denn dann da sind jetzt
eine technische frage ich glaube was
also zb der bundesrat in erwägung zieht
als gegenvorschlag gegen die
volksinitiative die not wird ist eine
erweiterte widerspruchslösung das heißt
dass die angehörigen dann mit in
betracht gezogen werden könnten und dann
entlässt sich entscheiden müssen werden
jetzt auch keine normen oder nicht im
sinne der betroffenen person und wenn
dann also meine angehörigen sagen würden
doch ich glaube er hätte das gewollt
dann gilt lässt sich das bei der
erweiterten widersprach es wird wir
sprechen von mächten von höheren mächten
es gibt viel mächtiger sind als die
politik das ist die macht der zeit
unserer ist jetzt vorbei deswegen würde
ich ihn noch die letzte frage stellen
wenn sie eine harte grenze mit ihren
eigenen intuition ziehen wollten von das
darf der staat mit einem körper nicht
tun da ist die absolute unverhandelbare
grenze kurze antwort bitte wo legt sie
für sie ich glaube ich wird bezug nehmen
auf wo sie vorhin gesagt haben nämlich
den pluralismus der guten lebensformen
es gibt eine unglaubliche vielzahl von
gelingenden und guten
leben und wenn der staat im lichte einer
zu engen konzeption eingreift in ein
leben was an und für sich gut ist und
auch anderen personen gegenüber
rechtfertigbar dann ist das das
überschreiten das unentschuldbare
überschreiten der grenze wirklich sagen
ich glaube dass das der der schutz der
würde unbedingt zu achten ist und das
bedeutet die grenze ist dann erreicht
wenn mir zu gunsten des kollektiven
körpers des gesellschafts körpers etwas
zugemutet wird was ich nicht was ich aus
guten gründen nicht will
ich glaube die haben die 30 sekunden um
noch einmal nachzufragen nämlich dass
jetzt gerade so interessiert pluralität
der lebensformen jetzt jemand zuhört und
sagt genau das ist meine lebensform dass
impfungen bei mir nicht stattfinden ich
glaube an naturheilmittel ich glaube an
andere formen von heilung was man darf
dann nicht gelten
aber was ich mit der pluralität von
lebensformen gemeint haben ist zunächst
einmal eine vielzahl von lebensformen
die gut sind für mich und ich würde
sagen diese frage müssen wir
unterscheiden noch mal von der frage ob
meine lebensform auch anderen personen
gegenüber rechtfertigbar ist und wenn
ich mit meiner lebensform anderen
personen schade dann sind staatliche
eingriffe eher zu rechtfertigen
ja aber es ist eine schwierige frage
frau flaßpöhler verräter wie schön dass
sie heute wieder da waren ja und auch
ihnen zu hause ganz herzlichen dank fürs
zuschauen nächste woche trifft mein
kollege ist postauto als musiker
schriftsteller ist 86 jahre alt und
putzmunter vielleicht nichts an seinem
10 buddhismus wir werden es hoffentlich
erfahren
und jetzt gleich geht's ab in einen
stall nach wales zwei brüder haben einen
bauernhof umgebaut und ein veritables
tonstudio daraus gemacht indem
musikgeschichte geschrieben worden ist
vielen dank fürs interesse bleiben sie
gesund auch oder gerade um ihre selbst
drinnen
[Musik]